sir I want to start with congratulations
thank you man I feel like I've been
talking to you about this movie for 10
years yes and I can't believe I'm at the
Black Adam junket talking to you about
Black Adam it's crazy it is I I have to
start 10 years it's been forever yeah
like I can multiple set visits anyway I
the I have to bring up I heard you were
the reason
instrumental you are the reason why um
something at the after the credits
happens I heard you were directly
responsible and I wanted to know why it
was so important to you for that to be
included in the movie sure I am
friends with that person
who we're talking about I'm trying to be
by the way good for the people in the
room that have not seen it right right
so the person that you're talking about
who is in uh who's in Black Adam that's
the big surprise
um that person we are good friends that
person is very good friends with my
business partner Danny Garcia who
has worked very closely in advocating
for his career over the years as manager
Hiram Garcia our president
friends with that person we've known
we've all known each other for a very
long time almost over 10 years
when I have said to fans
the hierarchy of power in the DC
Universe is about to change that was I
enjoyed saying that it kind of started
some Rumblings then I transitioned that
to feels like there's a new era in the
DC Universe that's getting ready to
happen now that new era that I'm talking
about it wasn't just hyperbole to try
and promote the movie
what I meant by that are a few things
number one was we have an opportunity to
really expand the DC Universe a universe
that I love man I grew up a DC kid you
too
and I'm still a big ass DC kid like
nothing's changed so we have an
opportunity to expand and introduce five
new characters from the DC Bible Black
Adam and the JSA and if you do your
homework and you know in mythology you
see with some of the other characters of
where we're going to where we could go
with them too as well
expansion
what it also means when I say
um
there's a new era in the DC Universe
what I mean by that man is listening to
the fans
and really paying attention to them
and not just saying you're listening to
them but really listening to them and
what I have been
a little frustrated with over the years
is when fans speak up and they're saying
something so loudly and no one is
addressing them and no leadership is
stepping in and saying okay we hear you
here's our plans here's where we're
going you may not like it but I respect
you enough and we respect you enough
here's we're going to have dialogue
there's it's been void of that so when I
so when we do say that when I say about
this is a new era in the DC Universe it
is listening to the fans
and we're not we're not always going to
be able to
do everything that they want but we are
going to listen so that the person
you're talking about the person you're
talking about is a reflection of not
only listening to the fans but you've
got a guy who
embodies
that you got a guy
who embody Superman listen he he is
[ __ ] awesome in that role it made me
so happy like that scene it it just made
me so happy and I know it's going to
make so many fans happy you know what I
mean like but so was it did you well I
mean listen I could keep going on on
this but um let me switch to something
else something that I was nervous about
going into the movie was that you've
been on like a family trajectory you've
been playing a certain role and I was
nervous will he really kill people you
know what I mean and um obviously you
kill all the bad guys you do not pull
any punches
um can you sort of talk about um that
aspect that this is the Black Adam that
people you know what I mean like it is
it is great to see you it's ruthless
yeah it was great to watch thank you man
and well that was a big deal for me
because it was a real departure from
anything that I've done in the past
throughout my career and if I was going
to do right by the character and the
mythology of Black Adam Black Adam kills
people
he rips them in half he's brutal and he
is ruthless and fueled by that Rage of
losing his family uh so I
ran to this opportunity to do this not
oh I just got to kill people it was just
more what a challenge this is so our
director John mccolet Sarah really
helped me a lot
um and getting this character up on its
feet so I was very happy about that I'm
already out of time I'm just going to
say go ahead oh are you are you sure no
two minutes go ahead okay one of the
things that by the way thank you and the
reason why I want to do this is because
even over 10 years ago we had a
conversation I don't remember this but
you said here don't stop to start the
clock yet
um
but you were talking to Kevin feige
and you told Kevin back then year over
10 years ago where's my at you hear so
yeah so 10 years ago he said to Kevin
on the item prompted at all and we had
almost maybe just met but he goes you
know someone who's like you should
really think about being a superhero is
Dwayne Johnson dude I'll never forget
that I really it meant a lot to me
because you didn't have to do that and I
appreciate it I'm just going to point
out to you that and you won't remember
this but um and then I really want to
ask a separate question about the movie
but on GI Joe the sequel you might not
remember me visiting you on set and be
convincing you to take a photo of all of
us and putting it on Instagram so I
could write that we were on the set of
the movie later that day you did video
of the vehicles I was so happy because
I'm like oh this is a great story and it
was the beginning or be anyway let's go
into this so real fast um one of the
things that I love in the movie is the
fight sequence between you and Hawkman
and the apartment it is brutal it's shot
in an Innovative cool way it is unlike
what you've seen all the other superhero
movies can you talk about filming that
fight sequence and how Innovative and
cool it is yeah so jalma who is our
director and he was really impassioned
about shooting this
tight space
how do superheroes fight in this tight
space but then also it really allowed us
on our end to showcase the super powers
that Black Adam has to the world so in
terms of moving at light speed he could
punch Hawkman and before Hawkman even
hits the wall Black Adam could be right
there on the other side he's that fast
so I really loved the fight that he was
able to put together that all of us were
it was brutal but then also
in those moments it's I think it's just
so badass to Showcase just how badass
Hawkman actually is I mean that is a
badass superhero man so I loved all the
Black Adam Hawkman fights I think we
delivered for the fans on that and
across the board I feel like we
introduced all the characters nicely
what do you think I would have was gonna
make a joke but I could do it a longer
cut I could see even more in the movie
yeah but I think all this is great as
Hawkman and I think that the stuff
between the two of you and I know I know
I gotta get the hell out of this room
but everyone uh if I would love to even
see even more and I look forward listen
there's going to be a huge hit I look
forward to the sequel and I say this
With all sincerity uh thank you for the
after the credit scene it meant a great
deal to me I think that that that man is
a fantastic
you know and um I just want to thank you
because I really did hear it was
directly you for making that happen it
got to a point where well collectively I
want to say myself Danny and Hiram we
said
here's how the movie should end and I'll
give you one further
test it
doesn't work we'll never talk about it
again test it
we shot it
to their credit new leadership oh sure
yeah exactly what I'm talking about yep
new leadership they saw it and said we
don't even have to test it